Monty Python inspired absurdity
Scientology controversies and post-covet
satire Comedy Central South Park has
never shied away from controversy is it
the Holy Grail of animated sitcoms or
just plain sacrilegious
South Park creators Matt Stone and Trey
Parker owe a great deal of credit to
Monty Python the British sketch comedy
Collective that Rose to prominence in
the 1960s and 70s with their unique
brand of absurd satirical humor the
group consisted of Comedy icons
including John Cleese Graham Chapman and
Eric idle whose many projects heavily
influenced Parker and stone throughout
the early development process of South
Park particularly the show's iconic art
style was influenced by the Terry
Gilliam animations that introduced their
BBC sketch series Monty Python's Flying
Circus over the years Stone and Parker
have had the opportunity to pay tribute
to their comedy heroes in celebration of
the troop's 50th Anniversary they
contributed to South Park recreation of
the iconic dead parrot sketch with
Cartman attempting to return a dead
Kenny to the prince store I'll tell you
what's wrong with him on that he's dead
no no he's uh he's resting the troops
Reunion Show at the O2 in London in 2014
was apparently sparked by the South Park
Duo although Idol jokingly countered
this claim in a Reddit AMA by saying
they are arrogant little twerps trying
to get cheap publicity off our backs
Idol's comment was likely ingest given
that the comedian provided the voice of
Dr vosnocker and South Park bigger
longer and uncut the South Park Duo also
had a relationship with python member
and film director Terry Gilliam who once
advised the two to not overextend
themselves across several projects that
advice was promptly ignored as the pair
produced South Park alongside several
feature films
this is our show
hey I'm not fat I'm big boned the
success of South Park has been the
subject of discussion in the
entertainment industry ever since it
first premiered it's not incredibly
surprising that the show took off given
its success as a viral video in the
internet's infancy but the first
episode's debut on Comedy Central in
1997 was no accident either
unfortunately test audiences weren't
responsive to the series first episode
which made the network hesitate in
giving the boys a further Chance season
one was nevertheless the subject of a
fierce marketing campaign by Comedy
Central as a last-ditch effort to draw
attention to it South Park even labeled
itself as the reason for parents to
install a v-chip in their television to
monitor their children's viewing habits
even before the first episode premiered
Comedy Central had already raked in a
fortune in t-shirt sales proving that
the series was to be an inevitable
success South Park is also responsible
for changing public opinion of Comedy
Central as a network entirely it had as
much of an influence on modern day TV as
shows like The Simpsons but the appeal
of South Park to a newer generation made
it a Surefire success for the network
and the show's creators
outside the world of internet memes and
pop culture South Park has even
influenced the world of law the show's
frequent mocking of celebrity songs and
moments have drawn plenty of discussion
over fair use and parody law like the
time when Butters performed a viral song
originally made by the internet
personality Samwell the resulting
lawsuit was eventually dismissed but it
set a precedent concerning fair use laws
South Park has also pervaded the Lexicon
of not just American culture but of the
American court system as well this
influence started in the season 2
episode Chef Aid which revolves around
chefs suing Alanis Morissette for
plagiarizing him hired by Morissette's
record label celebrity lawyer Johnny
Cochran who notably defended O.J Simpson
during his widely publicized murder
trial successfully argues for his client
by using what's now known as the
Chewbacca defense why would a Wookie an
eight foot tall Wookie want to live on
indoor with a bunch of two foot tall
Ewoks that does not make sense although
Chewbacca himself isn't often mentioned
in lawsuits the term Chewbacca defense
now blankets any argument made by the
prosecution or defense that is meant to
deliberately confuse the Theory as
recently as 2022 the South Park episode
was referenced during a federal tax
fraud case in Jacksonville Florida
however the argument's efficacy when not
employed by Cochrane in South Park
hasn't had much success
even though South Park had only been
airing on Comedy Central for two seasons
in 1999 it had already become a pop
cultural phenomenon naturally this
warranted a transition to the big screen
with Parker and stone co-producing the
first South Park feature film South Park
bigger longer and uncut Parker assumed
directorial duties for the film which he
co-wrote with stone and Veteran South
Park writer Pam Brady the film Center is
on the typical South Park kid sneaking
into an R-rated screen of Terence and
Phillip the final language in the movie
gets them to start swearing resulting in
a nationwide Panic that causes the
United States to declare war in Canada
just remember what the npaa says
horrific deplorable violence is okay as
long as people don't say any naughty
words if that wasn't wild enough on its
own the whole thing is a musical
featuring some delightfully vulgar songs
bigger longer and uncut was well
received Washington Post critic Rita
kempley wrote in her review they
outrageously profaned South Park bigger
longer and uncut takes Wicked Wax at
Targets ranging from Saddam Hussein to
the notion that the entertainment
industry is chiefly blame for the
pollution of kids culture despite the
film's lampooning of the entertainment
industry and censorship South Park
bigger longer and uncut was a success in
its own right it was the highest
grossing R-rated movie ever for a time
and the musical number blamed Canada
even garnered an Academy Award
nomination for best original song
however even the show's Oscar appearance
garnered controversy with ABC sensors
ironically requesting the performance of
a song be altered for Airy meanwhile
Parker and stone showed up to the
prestigious ceremony after taking LSD
wearing dresses previously worn by
Jennifer Lopez and Gwyneth Paltrow
while Parker and stone are best known as
the mines behind South Park for over 20
years they've also made waves in the
world of musical theater along with
Frozen songwriter Robert Lopez they
co-created the Smash Hit Broadway
musical The Book of Mormon the nine-time
Tony winning show premiered in 2011
starring Andrew Reynolds and Josh CAD as
two Mormon missionaries who were sent to
a poverty-stricken Ugandan Village to
spread their Faith Parker and Stone Met
Lopez after seeing his musical Avenue Q
during the production of their film Team
America World Police together the trio
bonded over their shared interest in
musical theater and Mormonism Parker and
stone grew up in a Mormon community in
Colorado and so Fascination however this
interest didn't start with the Book of
Mormon as the duo had previously taken
shots at the religion in earlier
projects in addition to their 1997 movie
Orgasmo which features Mormonism the duo
parodied the religion in season seven of
South Park the episode all about Mormons
follows a Utah family moving to South
Park and features a sequence explaining
how Joseph Smith founded the religion
even Mormons themselves have appreciated
the jokes with blogger Steve Evans
writing for or by Common consent South
Park argues that the social aspects of
our faith may be sufficient unto
themselves regardless of the efficacy of
our ordinances or the historicity of our
scriptures and maybe Joseph Smith did
make it all up but I have a great life
and a great family and I have the Book
of Mormon to thank for that
South Park has lampooned many
celebrities over the course of its 26
Seasons garnering more than enough Bad
Blood between the show's creators and
famous figures however one of the
series's most notable controversies came
during their ninth season when they
parodied the Church of Scientology
during the episode Trapped in the Closet
it famously featured a sequence
depicting the scientologist's origin as
well as the implication that several
celebrity scientologists are actually
closeted themselves one person in the
South Park Duo probably didn't
anticipate angering was Isaac Hayes the
singer-songwriter who played the iconic
role of Chef also a member of the Church
of Scientology Hayes announced in a
statement prior to season 10 that he
would be departing the show for their
disrespected religion the matter became
the subject of controversy for years to
come with Matt Stone telling the AP we
never heard a peep out of Isaac in any
way until we did Scientology he wants a
different standard for religions other
than his own the circumstances of
Hayes's departure have since been
contradicted some reports saying that
Hayes was also dissatisfied with pay or
had suffered a stroke nevertheless this
meant the end of Chef's time on South
Park when the character being killed off
in a season 10 premiere after being
struck by lightning and mauled by wild
animals the speed at which the South
Park production team moves has resulted
in some pretty close calls when it comes
to episodes airing one of the most
famous examples of this came during the
show's 12th season when the team decided
to do an episode that would air the day
after the 2008 presidential election
without knowing who would win the
episode's production was entirely
reliant on Trey Parker's hope that
Barack Obama would defeat John McCain
the South Park co-creator told the Los
Angeles Times that they considered
making two versions of the episode but
it wasn't feasible he elaborated well
we're just going to make the Obama
version and if McCain somehow wins we're
basically just totally screwed
[Applause]
thankfully for them Obama did inevitably
win the election allowing the team to
proceed with the episode as is however
they still Incorporated some of his
victory speech into the episode by the
morning of the day the episode aired it
was also decided by Parker and the other
members of the South Park team that the
episode's plot would be removed from
bipartisan politics instead Obama and
McCain would be attempting to pull off a
jewel Heist while the political
alignment of each recurring character
was decided arbitrarily during
production thankfully no one had to
worry for long about messing up the
election prediction but it made for an
incredibly lucky call by Parker South
Park has been no stranger to the world
of video games receiving its first
playable adaptation on the Nintendo 64
and Playstation in 1998. other South
Park video games have been released over
the years but they're essentially
existing games with a new coat of paint
that's why it eventually became a
priority for Parker and stone to
Faithfully translate the South Park
experience into a video game their dream
finally came true with South Park the
Stick of Truth which was released for
PlayStation 3 Xbox 360 and PC in 2014.
while previous South Park video games
had experimented with genres like first
person shooters and racing The Stick of
Truth is a role-playing game in which
players control the new kid during a
town-wide LARPing session though the
game was developed by Obsidian
Entertainment Parker and stone were
heavily involved in the game's design
they took heavy inspiration from
Nintendo's Earthbound another popular
RPG that Parker particularly loved the
game's development process was also
subject to similar difficulties as the
show itself sensors in different
countries resulted in humorous
workarounds by their development team
including in one scene where Randy Marsh
gets probed by aliens nevertheless like
the South Park TV show The Stick of
Truth was an incredible success
critically and commercially a sequel
released in 2017 South Park the
fractured butthole trades a medieval
fantasy role play of the Stick of Truth
for superhero alter egos like the rest
of the entertainment industry South Park
was affected by the covid-19 pandemic
thanks to the production team's quick
turnaround time on creating episodes
though they were able to release the
pandemic special in September of 2020 as
part of their 24th season this hour-long
special focuses on the town's reaction
to covid-19 as well as Randy Marsh's
role in spreading it it was Then
followed up in March 2021 with the South
Park vaccination special continuing the
storyline by addressing vaccines in Q
Anon conspiracies look you guys have a
right to say and believe whatever you
want okay but what you believe is really
stupid later in 2021 South Park extended
its deal with Comedy Central to produce
the show for up to 30 seasons including
two films that were planned to be
released that year the first of them was
South Park post covid a one-hour special
followed up by a second hour South Park
post covid the return of kovid unlike
the pandemic special the post-covet
specials did The Impossible and took a
look at the lives of the show's main
cast 40 years into the future the
specials find Stan returning to South
Park after Kenny has passed away
resulting in the Rio of Stan Kyle and
Cartman who's now a rabbi reuniting to
finish research on a kova 19 cure
eventually they discovered that Kenny
discovered time travel so Stan and Kyle
try using it to prevent the pandemic
they're unable to do so but they still
manage to improve the lives of everyone
they know except for Cartman
in 2022 South Park had its 25th
anniversary that was cause for
celebration for Parker and stone who
took the festivities to their home state
of Colorado and put on an extravagant
concert at the iconic Red Rocks
Amphitheater in Morrison the setlist
contained many musical hits from South
Park history including the
oscar-nominated blame Canada from South
Park bigger longer and uncut and the
anime inspired ninja Anthem lets
fighting love the concert also featured
special guests with band's wean and
Primus supporting Stone and Parker
throughout the concert however the
biggest surprises were Getty Lee and
Alex leifson from Rush who surprised not
only the audience but Stone too Stone
joined the duo on drums to perform the
Beloved Rush song closer to the heart a
once in a lifetime concert was performed
across two nights and later made
available to watch on Paramount plus and
YouTube It's a must watch for any South
Park fan as they'll get to see the
Geniuses behind the show celebrate
having one of the most successful
animated shows of all time for 25 years
here's the many more anniversaries on
the horizon
foreign